awful lot of you people watching the
show may have no idea what a studio art
director does and I guess the best way
to explain it would be to say that he is
an instant architect in other words if
you give him an unlimited budget Rome
can be built in a day or at least the
front of it nobody had to go to the back
of the set it's my pleasure at this time
to introduce the very talented young
lady he was going to help present the
award for art direction a former Academy
Award winner for her performance in
razor's edge she has to be assisted by a
gentleman who has won my admiration over
the years for the ease with which he
makes comedy scene as simple as laughter
itself Miss Anne Baxter and mr. Fred
MacMurray
Jack nominees for best achievement in
art direction of a black-and-white
picture
Amerika Amerika Gene Kelly Federico
Fellini's eight-and-a-half piero guitar
d HUD art direction Hal Pereira and Tami
last set decoration Sam comer and Robert
Bentley love with the proper stranger
art direction Hal Ferrara and Roland
Anderson set decoration Sam comer and
grace Gregory wild item on art direction
George W Davis and Paul Gross set
decoration
Henry Grace and huge the winner is Jean
Callahan for America America
thank you all
the nominees for best achievement in art
direction of a color picture the
Cardinal art direction Lyle peeler set
decoration Jean Callahan Cleopatra hold
on now this is the picture for art
direction
John Deker Jack Martin Smith
Hilliard Brown Herman Blumenthal Elvin
web Laurie spelling and Boris you rock
set decoration
Walter him Scott Paul s Fox and
rainwater come blow your horn art
direction Hal Ferrara and Roland
Anderson set decoration Sam comer and
James Payne How the West was won art
direction George W Davis William Ferrari
and Addison hair set decoration Henry
grace Don Greenwood jr. and Jack
Miller's Tom Jones art direction Ralph
printin Ted Marshall and Jocelyn Herbert
set decoration Joe szema cabin the
winner is John Deker Jack Marcus Smith
in your bra
Portland Blumenthal Albert Webb motors
coming the Borgia rockefeller
you're not all here ladies and gentlemen
not all of us are here the rest of our
team is in Italy all five of them and we
want to extend to the Academy a big
THANK YOU from them with us especially
John to cure our production designer and
Hillyard Brown the Admiral of our fleet
thank you so much
it's all set they get together they melt
them down and Cleopatra gets off the nut
this